so you see enough of these CGI kids
movies and you consistently love them
and you start to think to yourself am I
going crazy so I'm here with my buddies
the schmoes from schmoes neucom which is
still hard to say to talk more about
Megamind
[Music]
and I'll tell you what I love this movie
and it seems to me look I guarantee that
if you go back to look at all the
animation it really seems that we love
animation and we're never talking crap
about it we love them all
we're idiot we know when we try to
especially this time of year returns
like about Oscar movies he's highfalutin
heart rate to drop listen it's like it's
like it's like putting a parrot for a
rabbit we come in we pretend that these
adult problems as soon as you put this
3d glasses on see a big blue forehead
pop man you just enjoy we're
suckers for real 3d bees the 3d this
film was awesome I mean the 3d was great
in this movie and I'll tell you what
we'll reach a compromise keep the 3d in
the CGI movies and we'll all be good it
looks great in this movie and it looked
great in the past for CGI movies I've
seen the cinematography was awesome and
the action scenes were cooler than most
things I've seen lately flying around in
a really impressively rendered 3d CGI
metropolis is awesome now what I liked
about Megamind is that it has a hero in
it I mean kind of briefly but it is all
about Megamind and here's the thing you
actually care I personally wasn't a big
fan of Despicable Me man I don't know
why maybe it's because I don't have kids
I don't know but I just didn't connect
with it which is really funny because
mega Minds also about a villain so you
think it's the same movie made on it but
it's really not as much as you can
humanize as much saying this you're
exactly right because it's all about how
you unfold a story I like how Megamind
was told and I cared about Megamind more
than I cared about the penguin and uncle
Fester's love child and Despicable Me or
maybe my heart just grew three sizes
this weekend I don't know I mean he
shows Megamind as a kid in elementary
school and he's that kid that nobody
likes he's picked last and all the
sports which is ultimately most of us in
elementary school I mean there's the
popular kids like the top one or two
percent then there's the rest and
Megamind appeals to the rest
the beginning of the film they set up
why he is this way and he was the last
gift to kickball even all this stuff
that was you know it's a and you can you
felt form you know he turned out to be a
good people and while you're watching
your movie with your relatable villain
you have a soundtrack that absolutely
kicks ass I mean just great music crazy
train bad to the bone they even bust
have some MJ blowing your nose big chin
and your music kick-ass rock you got
ac/dc you got you got some other special
surprises in there it's a it is a fun
roller coaster ride movie and again it's
known for its a cartoon and it's made
for beer drinking and all that goes
where add pin is in the movie as Metro
Man I mean ever so briefly but let's
face it the guy has superhero voice he's
the perfect choice now is there a better
voice to cast as a superhero than that
of Brad Pitt world famous actor action
star Joey wants to in fact I don't even
think he knew he was being recorded for
an animation I think they just bugged
his house and they recorded his voice as
he was randomly talking in his bathroom
but he did a very good one so
congratulations all that time you things
people spend hang on Italy filming
oceans 19 movies and I like that the
movie addresses that if the villain wins
I mean now what I mean just as the Joker
needs Batman Megamind needs Metro Man if
the villain wins then he is set for life
with all the money he wants in the most
boring existence ever thought of I think
this is such a goldmine for comics in my
mind it is is that supervillain where he
finally you know it seems like he takes
care of a good guy now all of a sudden
he's got nothing to do it was always my
favorite dynamic
Batman's series is that the Joker he
wants to he's always going after Batman
then he finally gets him in one of the
comic books and he's like these feds
arrested a comic just like he's like
reviewing movies nothing else to do I'm
just not sure that I've seen a superhero
movie deal with that fact I mean you see
it in comic books a lot but I mean in
terms of movies I think this might
actually be the first don't kill the
good guys because then you're I mean
Metro Man got along just fine he's
playing a little banjo little ukulele
like Tiny Tim and but what's
Megamind gonna do in all this is most
definitely the same character and
everything but it worked for this movie
it really did I can see him being so a
really creepy that now he's just pissed
and he's gonna destroy but that is
kind of what you get screwed with when
you look like the dude chick from it's
pay at the movie three point six out of
five suppose and it would have gotten to
the four to the 401 but it is it is long
and it drags in the middle there's about
15 minutes in the middle where it's like
guys this is a cartoon alright let's
let's let's pick up the pace a little
bit there's like you can go to the
bathroom and then you can get some
popcorn and you go to the bank and buy
some stamp you can you have a lot of
time to fill in the middle this movie
that could have been accordion kind of
like that rant I will also definitely
say check out mega Minds you have three
out of three people here telling you to
check it out if you haven't checked it
out by now I mean go check it out it's a
good time even if you don't have kids
I'd like to think the schmoes from
schmoes no calm for doing this
collaborative video with me and having
good taste in movies that always helps
and if you like what you've seen here
you want to check out more of me or the
schmoes then click right here to see
more
[Music]